avec pierre laurin aux journalistes
écrivant un spécialiste de la russie
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france ce 9 mai 2000 vent devait marquer
le coup en russie ce n'est que partie
remise
oui effectivement d'abord bonjour et
bonne fête de la victoire
je crois que hélas la pandémie retarde
des célébrations que de toute manière
auront lieu un peu plus tard dans
l'année
ce qui est important aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement de marquer cette date qui
est très importante pour la russie
beaucoup plus importante d'ailleurs que
pour les pays occidentaux qui considère
que la victoire sur le nazisme a été un
événement historique certes très
important mais qui n'était pas forcément
qui n'a pas reconnu forcément la même
dimension que en union soviétique avec
un bilan humain qui est absolument
catastrophique puisque plus de la moitié
des morts de la seconde guerre mondiale
ont été russe ou soviétique
expliquez nous le symbole de cette date
le 9 mai dans la mémoire collective
qu'est ce que ça représente aux yeux des
russes
eh bien ça représente quelque chose de
très important
c'est à dire aujourd'hui c'est
l'équivalent d'une fête nationale
en fait pendant toute la période
soviétique la fête nationale c'était le
7 novembre c'est-à-dire la fête de la
révolution d'octobre et là il y avait
une grande parade militaire sur la place
rouge où l'ont montré les derniers
développements de la technique pellicule
à partir de 91,2 1991 et l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique
cette célébration du 7 novembre n'a plus
eu lieu et les rues se sont retrouvés
orphelins d'une fête nationale il n'y
avait plus rien il y avait effectivement
la fête de l'indépendance qui est le 12
juin qui célèbre la proclamation de
souveraineté de la russie par rapport à
l'union soviétique en 1990 mais cela ne
parle pas à l'esprit
russe ceux qui parlent à l'esprit russe
en revanche c'est le sacrifice le
sacrifice de consentis par le peuple
russe et les peuples soviétique au
moment de la victoire et pendant la
guerre donc et la victoire
c'est un élément fédérateur c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
pour les russes parce que c'est l'inde
une des clés de leur identité actuelle
il faut pour ce qui est essentiellement
grâce à cela du côté des occidentaux on
retient encore aujourd'hui que les
grands vainqueurs la seconde guerre
mondiale ce sont les américains on
entend beaucoup en parler du rôle à
jouer par la russie dans la victoire
contre l'allemagne nazie comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer du côté des
occidentaux c'est un tout petit peu
normal disons enfin même très normal la
mesure où ils ont joué sur le front
occidental le rôle essentiel et que sur
le front est sur le front oriental et
bien finalement c'était les soviétiques
qui sont devenus tout de suite après la
guerre l'adversaire potentiel principal
l'adversaire idéologique et en un mot
les ennemis de la guerre froide
donc il y a toujours eu une tendance à
magnifier le rôle des américains et des
occidentaux jeudi en général plutôt bien
entendu que celui des soviétiques même
si les soviétiques ont payé le plus
lourd tribut et techniquement
ce sont eux qui ont gagné la guerre
puisque au moment du débarquement de
normandie en en jeu à 44 les russes
enfin les soviétiques étaient déjà en
pologne en europe centrale et étaient
prêts à déferler chemin de la sofma
devait donc être un rendez vous
diplomatiques à moscow c'est par
téléphone on la vit que la démerde
couture elle s'est entretenue avec
emmanuel macron hier le
président russe qui a donc évoqué la
coopération entre la russie et la france
le président français insistant lui sur
l'importance du dialogue stratégique
entre paris et moscou
ce cas se traduit comment aujourd'hui
concrètement ce réchauffement des
relations franco-russes bien le
réchauffement se traduit d'une manière
très éparses
c'est à dire c'est un rapprochement
pointillés c'est à dire que les chefs
d'état
visiblement on envie d'aller de l'avant
de nouer des partenariats
il y a des contacts très fréquents et
très fécond entre les ministres par
exemple les ministres de la défense
ministres affaires étrangères mais
également au niveau économique mais
simplement ça ne suis pas derrière il ya
des blocages en particulier au niveau
non pas ministériel mais au niveau de la
de la haute administration de la
fonction publique qui estime qu' on peut
pas aller comme ça tout seul face à la
russie qu'il faut un accompagnement
européen
or l'accompagnement européens bloquent
sur un élément principal c'est les
sanctions les sanctions décrétées contre
la russie au moment de la crise
ukrainienne en 2014 qui sont en vigueur
et qui ne peuvent être réduites
ne parlons pas de les supprimer ou
simplement les réduire que si l'ensemble
des pays européens est d'accord
parallèlement à cela les américains ne
sont pas contre a parlé même sanction et
donc peu ils peuvent faire du commerce
avec la russie sur beaucoup beaucoup de
points qui sont interdits aux européens
donc il ya un déséquilibre mais le
problème de ce déséquilibre là c'est que
lorsque on et 27 puisque le royaume uni
est désormais hors de l'union européenne
lorsqu'on et 27 il est très difficile
d'établir un consensus sur des points
aussi sensible il suffit qu il ya un
pays où deux qui bloque et en
particulier les pays
de l'est européen en particulier la
pologne et les états baltes bloc pour
que les choses traînent en longueur
et c'est ça principalement qui entravent
un dialogue qui paraît si l'on écoute
les deux chefs d'état qui parle est
fécond il gomme les différences pour se
concentrer sur ce qui compte réellement
sur les relations entre les deux pays
ils essaient de trouver des voies pour
avancer en particulier en france et le
dialogue de trianon qui fonctionne très
très bien au niveau des sept des
sociétés civiles mais le blocage
politique en particulier le blocage dû à
l'imitation de l'europe dans ce dialogue
bilatéral
eh bien ça ne peut pas avancer aussi
facilement que les chefs d'état l'ombre
merci beaucoup pierre laurent
journaliste est spécialiste de la russie
ce